buenas noches en primer lugar bueno
si se confirmase realmente que se han
cometido crímenes de guerra constituyen
las más graves violaciones del derecho
internacional humanitario
evidentemente que podrían poner en
marcha todos los mecanismos para
proceder al enjuiciamiento de los
autores o presuntos autores de estos
crímenes el problema radica en
determinar la competencia realmente que
puedan tener los tribunales por lo que
se refiere a los tribunales alemanes
ello dependerá lógicamente de la
legislación alemana y de la posibilidad
de aplicar reglas relativas a la
jurisdicción universal en el caso de la
corte penal internacional la corte ya es
competente para investigar la situación
de violación de crímenes de guerra y el
derecho interna y de crímenes de lesa
humanidad que se está produciendo
ucrania porque ucrania ya le otorgó esa
competencia específicamente en dos
ocasiones la última en 2015 y además 38
estados de distintas regiones del mundo
han remitido el asunto a la corte penal
internacional para que la corte pueda
investigar esos casos y se identifica la
comisión específica de crímenes juzgar a
los responsables
en materia humanitaria qué pasa con las
víctimas de estos ataques que son
prácticamente en su totalidad civiles
quien los acompaña en terreno quien los
ayuda después de este tipo de
situaciones o de hechos
bueno es un tema de una pregunta difícil
de contestar la responsable en el marco
de un conflicto armado las normas del
derecho internacional humanitario
imponen a las partes en un conflicto el
respetar de manera plena a la población
civil eso significa lógicamente que
tienen que abstenerse de realizar actos
que
constituyan ataques directos contra la
población civil o contra bienes civiles
por ejemplo instalaciones de agua
electricidad
etcétera también significa que tienen
que desarrollar los combates de tal
manera que no se produzca un daño
innecesario en la población civil porque
evidentemente absteniéndose de
bombardear zonas
urbanas en las que no hay ningún
objetivo militar o utilizando armas que
no perjudiquen a que no perjudiquen
excesivamente a la población pero el
tema de quién es responsable de la
población civil
muy sencillo de contestar y muy difícil
de articular en la práctica son
responsables de proteger a la población
las hay en primer lugar como es lógico
las autoridades ucranianas pero también
todas las demás partes en conflicto es
decir tienen que responder de la
protección de esa población civil tanto
las tropas rusas como las autoridades
ucranianas y las tropas ucranianas y
otros combatientes que estén
participando
a ello obedece en buena medida toda la
polémica que se ha planteado en torno a
los corredores humanitarias